hello everybody welcome to another day
of chess on psychology hope you're
having a great day
um so far i'm having a right day
uh it's kind of raining here but it's
not stormy so
i'm good as long as i'm not
jumping up and down the thunders i guess
that's a
that's a big plus okay so today
i decided to show you um
one of my favorite games that i played
in um
it wasn't uh i don't remember the city
but i was playing
the switzerland bundesliga in seasons 26
15 16 and then 1617 so
i had some really interesting games
there i
actually scored 100 which was a
pretty cool deal for me um
let's see what else what did i like ah i
actually back in 2015 considered uh
living in switzerland and like changing
my federation to switzerland
but um i had some issues with language
barrier
and kind of ended up wanting to
live permanently in an english-speaking
country
so that didn't happen but this was a
very interesting game because
i specifically have been wanting to talk
about
not just how to beat weaker opponents or
how to
prepare against opponents or how to play
against
like much much higher rift opponents
which those are some of the things that
we have been
talking about in arches and psychology
recently
but whereas i kind of want to show how
to
um beat an opponent that is
almost exact same level as you are
so i think that's a big deal because
a lot of the players have this issue
even myself have this issue
that not necessarily we always know how
to play
or what opening to choose or just
what does an opponent who is maybe like
uh around our rating or our strength
knows uh how much chess he knows
basically
so for me when i'm playing like 200 less
200 more
um i kind of have a clear idea of
kind of what to expect when i when i'm
playing something like that difference
but when the difference gets closer to
like 50 points
or somewhere even less than that
then it's kind of it's really hard
to figure that out so in this specific
game i was playing against
um okay good luck
wish me luck with my pronunciation
skills uh
hush hutches strasser
michael oh god uh who was
i think a feeder master or international
master
um with the rating 2330 in 2016
and i was 2016 earlier in
2016 january so i was still just the w i
am
and my rating was 23 15
and yeah january was a good month
so um oh yeah this was right after
christmas i remember i played qatar open
in 2015
and i flew directly i went from qatar
back to iran
switched suitcases and flew to
switzerland and my mom and my brother
were already in switzerland
and we had the new year eve there which
was actually kind of nice yeah i kind of
missed hanging with my family oh we need
i need my family's immigration case to
process
faster right okay
um so non-chess
stuff aside let's talk about the
chess behind this event so um
i was playing for um
i think it was the first year that i was
playing for
this uh switzerland high league and i
ended up
winning all my games that i played and
um
we actually won the uh the title
for the first time but okay
so my main opening
is nimzo indian um with against d4c4 i
tried king's indian which i showed a
game
last time i kind of
tried the um queen's gambit
kind of not really my style either
i tried some groomfeld i mean i like it
but it's um still
i it's not that comfortable for me so
names are indian it is so um for those
of you who play nimzo indian
you know that this e3 is
um kind of a big deal because you have
to know
exactly what you're doing so the thing
with e3
is that there are so many different
lines now
one of them is to take i prefer to take
only after this a3 has been played
because
without this a3 then this bishop a3s um
could potentially be a little bit
annoying in my experience
um but ideally i would like to have this
um
two it's this double pawn and this is
something that we've covered previously
how to play against this um these double
pawns
so a lot of the players prefer to do
castle and then later on if necessary
they bring their bishop back to e7 or
if they have to they take on c3 so it
really depends
on we it kind of depends on
what we're looking for in that game so
my favorite
used to be this c5 just because
of this knight e2 line the only
difference between
uh the only big difference between doing
castle or
c5 earlier is this knight e2
so when you do c5 earlier and after
knight e2 you get the chance to actually
take on d4
and this was what i wanted to get at um
so finally we get the chance to castle
so so far it doesn't look like we have
like any clear
plan right so if you don't know this
opening
at first glance you're gonna probably
think okay
and everything seems somewhat of an
equal we got king safety
white's got some center and some space
um
what else can we think about we could
consider the fact that
this bishop is still underdeveloped so
we should try to um
figure out what to do with this bishop
one of it could be try to
fianchetto it another is trying to do d5
another
idea could be d6 e5 so you kind of have
these three options on what to do with
your bishop
it kind of depends on what whites does
because
well a3 is one of the main lines
another main line is this ideas with
bishop f4
um and with bishop f4 this kind of
delays your d6 e5 right so you can't
really do that
as easily so that's one thing to kind of
keep in mind um i
see in the chat that you guys are kind
of looking for
tactics unfortunately this game does not
have
much of tactics in it just because
well white kind of prevented it with the
e3 and knight e2
if i didn't do this c5 and if i just
play it like
very uh slowly slowly then the idea
behind knight e2
is that eventually wants to get this
f3 e4 not right now but eventually
and the knight is not on f3 to block it
another idea that could be out there
is um just with the knight on e2
this knight f4s and d5s could become
a little bit more supported compared to
having the knight on f3
so those are some of the general things
to keep in mind when thinking about e3
and
choosing what you want to do as black
so my opponent played a3 bishop e7 just
because well i don't really want to take
this anymore it just takes at night
and i just gave up my two bishops the
center is still mobile and
i don't really feel like this is
um going to be a very easy game for me
so let's go back
play bishop e7 bishop f4
sorry knight f4 uh bishop before is also
possible but it kind of like you have to
figure out what you want to do with this
bishop to be able to cast all
so i don't think bishop f4 right now is
the
smartest choice yes this bishop would
be pretty would look pretty good on this
diagonal because it has so many squares
but um at the same time bishop on f4
you're blocking this knight you're
delaying
your development you're delaying castle
so let's not
try to do that let's go for knight f
form
and so my first question to you guys
what do you want to do with this bishop
you have some choices you have those
three choices between d5
d6 e5 or b6 so what do you guys want to
do
do you want to um
simply play b6 you want to try
d5 what do you want to do
okay i have one b6 oh i have one d6
i wish i kind of had a pole right now
but did not prepare that
oh i only have one d5 interesting
so for those of you who are suggesting
d6 i assume that you
want to follow up with e5 right
so i think that's interesting i think
that's a good idea um
so i chose d6 with the idea e5
d5 is also possible i am not the biggest
fan of b6
just because then there should be two
bishop b7
and now castle
and um sooner or later there is
your bishop is going to get close
because you kind of have to try and get
this knight out either with
dc d5 um or
you're going to close your bishop either
with d5 or with your knight
if you decide to do d697 then what is
the future for
this knight on d7 so
um yeah let's try to figure out
how to develop so i think those were
some
big things that i considered
trying to decide well where to develop
and
okay so i went for d6 with the idea e5
and um the knight could end up on e4 but
the problem is that
even if you do like with these knights
here this d5 is something that's always
going to
be bothering you so that's something
that's
i didn't really want to deal with i just
wanted to get my bishop
out uh this way without having to deal
with the fianchettos that would also
weaken some of my squares
okay so um
in the game my opponents went bishop e3
so do you guys think
right now we should play the e5 keep in
mind if you play e5
take take that the queens could get
exchanged
oh hello i'm good how are you
i think i have cat hair on my face but
besides that i feel
quite good
it's one of the perks of having a cat
the hair gets everywhere
i find it on my face fun fact with when
you have a cat
you might want to invest a lot and lots
of lint rolls
because i actually would throw my face
i didn't say that i don't even throw my
face right
but yeah that's actually the best way to
um
get rid of the cat hair uh gets in the
mask
gets on the laptop but yes
but that's something that i have to um
talk to my cat about stop shedding
okay we are looking into e5 okay so i
have um
ah interesting so we have something um
to try to do like queen b6 huh
interesting
so i think with b6 is
i think queen b6 would be quite nice but
the thing is with queen b6 you're not
really threatening
this b2 because let's say
white just plays bishop d3 then are you
actually going to take this because then
knight a4 and your queen is getting
trapped
so i don't really think it's a um
it's a good idea to play queen b6 just
because
you're not threatening anything if it
actually had a serious threat then yes
i would i would like it
let's see so let's say we do something
just
very chill and we simply just develop
so i think um knight
uh c6 is
interesting but the
problem is that this d5 is coming up
so either you're gonna have to deal with
this d5 by taking it ideally we want to
play
e5 instead of taking because when you
take
and then well anything take back is
i like it anything even pawn i think is
fine
now knight e5 and you're having some
issues with this bishop it's kind of
blinded um
what else can we think of
yeah well you could try to develop this
bishop that's like
you could think about that but i
like just looking at it i want to be
white i don't want to be black in this
position
so i prefer this uh
not to be i don't want to get into this
position i don't want to have to
um wish that i was my opponent you know
um so in this position we can play
something like
e5 uh but still with e5
then yes you opened up this bishop
but you're still having issues with your
dark squared bishop
let's say if take take can i take on b7
you take back take here
ah now i kind of feel like black is
doing all right because we have this
rook e8
bishop is kind of grounded
so yeah i think actually this does give
black some interesting chances
um but what about just taking back on
on um
f4 because if we take back then
take back
and
i don't know this position still feels
too wobbly
so yeah i don't i don't want to be
i don't want to deal with this pressure
i prefer to be the one who's putting the
pressure
um even just psychologically it's going
to be a pretty hard game because
i'm not really going to be able to do
this
uh d5 like okay let's say if we play d5
now
it's not really threatening anything
yeah maybe you could do d4
but then the night i it's white's
activity white's pieces coordination
what's putting the pressure so
i don't really
like this and
all right so
that is another reason why we why i
didn't really
want to do this knight c6 and why we
should be committed to this e5
so after e5 it's very important
to understand this pawn end game
so sorry
the pawn structure of this end game
so um as you can see it's
uh it's a kind of a
minority a majority type of deal
so white has this pawn majority on the
queen side and we have this palm
majority on the
kings i think i'm having some
problem with wards and
so
let me reorganize my thoughts
this is a type of pawn structure that we
are going
to get uh in a lot of different
positions
from a lot of different openings so it's
really important to understand the
concepts of
how to do the pawn majority attacks
because right now white has this
majority
in um in queenside
and black has a maturity in the king
side
and so it kind of means that if we kind
of like
wait long enough then white is going to
just start pushing
start pushing and since white doesn't
have a king here uh white doesn't have
to worry about
weakening his king however because we
have
this majority on the king side if we
start pushing then we are
actually going to be worried about what
to do with our king
so um
in this position white made the good
choice of playing knight d5 because if
whites did
anything else like knight d3 we're just
going to develop
and you can see that black's pieces
activity pieces coordination
we have better so means we're doing
better
uh now like like white actually has to
play it a little faster like if white
just plays super chill with bishop e2
now we're gonna go start attacking these
pawns
if you just keep on playing chill we're
just gonna keep on pushing and
pushing so
okay so nice d5 question for the
audience
how do you guys want to continue in this
position what do you want to do what do
you want to take something
do you want to just move your bishop
what do you think
i'm reading the chats oh god you guys
are
really killing it huh
so i see one knight c6
my c6 um so are you willing to give up
this bishop like
because we do we would benefit from
having
our two bishops so
i understand you want to develop but at
the same time
we'd kind of have to take the night like
i don't think
it's um it's just one of those moves you
have to do it not because it's um
not because it's the only move but
because
um we kind of have to do this
because if we don't then we're gonna
have some issues like
it's not that it's the only move like if
you don't do it you're gonna lose
like knight c6 is still not that big of
an issue
but the problem is that in a long run
you're not going to benefit from this
move
also something with like moving your
bishop to cover up c7 as well because
knight c7 was coming
then you're still not going to benefit
from this pawn structure
or even something simpler c5
now attacking the bishop so
okay
um let's go back to
exactly 97 is trapping the rook so
that's why we also have to seriously
consider taking
another thing is that you just
don't want to in this specific position
you don't
want to give up the tempe like
if you are going to give up two bishops
then it's better to
um have one bishop one night
for the two bishops extreme instead of
like letting your opponent
keep one night because then that knight
can still jump around but if you are the
one who
has a knight then your knight is
stronger than
so if you have two knights one bishop
compared to two bishops one night
that's usually not um as good as having
again depending on the position but it's
not usually as beneficial
to have that compared to like one
night on the board that is yours and two
bishops opponent one bishop of you
so um i think that's something to
um like just keep in mind
okay so i hope i explained that well
cause um i guess if i didn't i'm gonna
hear back from you guys
okay so take take and in this position
we kind of have to um
play this knight c6 because
unfortunately if we play bishop d6 then
we have to play
then we have to face the c5s and the
little tactics of taking
doesn't work well actually this does
work but
just taking right now doesn't work
because of simply knight c7 and then
oops your rook is trapped and we don't
really want to have that right
so uh can we isolate the c
pound somehow well ideally yeah that's
the goal we want to try and isolate that
but right now it's quite hard to do just
because
well how are you gonna get rid of the b2
pawn
so knight c6 take take
rook d1 so question shall we take that
rook or
should we just develop this bishop
oh the cat is tripping
[Music]
okay yeah let's take i agree we gotta
take that
and now okay so now we are actually in a
critical position
how are you going to develop your pieces
where are you going
to place your um well the remainder of
your
material you don't have that much of it
left so
where how are you going to um
develop where are you going to put the
bishop where you're going to put the
knight
bishop f5 i think bishop f5 is
interesting
but we have to make a choice do we want
bishop f5 or knight to f5
yeah if you not necessarily if you play
knight
c6 then well you kind of wasted a move
you just played knight c6 and then you
took on e7 and then you came back
actually wasted two moves so
um
yeah we can play this knight f5 also
also
uh didn't you guys uh say
tell me about trying and attacking this
guy so we could achieve that with bishop
v6
and potentially knight d6
so why not yeah let's go with knight f5
um in the game i saw this idea
and i really wanted to go after it also
because bishop f5
just you're not really your bishop is
taking away the d3 square from this
bishop okay
true i agree but still bishop can come
here can go to f3
it's not really doing that much good and
you really need to activate this knight
the
if you are going to get an advantage if
you're going to
have the upper hand is going to be
because of this night
because you have this um
because you have that that night because
that's what your opponent doesn't have
so that's that's kind of
another type of reasoning because you
got that knight you gotta activate it
so knight f5 king d2
so what are we gonna do are we going to
take this guy
do you think it's right to want to
pick that up while you are thinking
about this
what to do after king d2 i'd like to
point out
if white just tried to develop i would
definitely take this
especially because it would kind of mess
up the pawn structure
bishop of five and we're gonna
everything is getting out so fast the
bishop of five rook d8
and i'm not saying that this endgame is
like winning for black but this is
definitely better for black
just the activity of the pieces and the
fact that well
your bishop is kind of it's not really
doing anything
you you can't even play bishop f3
because you get this rd3
so yeah exactly
yep so that's why
um i would definitely i would be very
happy with this
how the things are going and i would
just now it would be the right time to
push right
and now um we're just gonna try and
simply bring in the king or play like a
b3 b6
to um face potential um
scrutiny's there but i kind of prefer to
bring the king to be honest
okay anyways let's go back
unfortunately my opponent didn't do this
king bishop e2 and did king d2 so
now now what shall we take that um
from the most of the chat is saying no
yeah i agree if we were to take this
then bla
white would take with king and the king
is now activated
and now the bishop is also coming to d3
yeah you can play the special f5 but
then bishop v2
the king is way too activated just
comparing the king
makes me very sad so we don't want to
help our opponent activate his pieces
rule number well one of end game
actually might be yeah between having a
pass bomb
and activating the king
both of them should be rule number one
right okay
um so
if we're not gonna take then what are we
gonna do we have to develop right
so let's get the bishop out let's start
putting pressure
um so i don't really
think there was any other good ideas
because like i don't see
anything much better from bishop b2 i
think like bishop d3 is
also possible but we would still do this
rook d8 with the idea e4
now uh if when you move the king um
well if king e2 now i would still
have oh i kind of want e4 can i do that
this looks pretty uh this looks
interesting but even if i don't really
want to do this e4
i could still just try with this and
now my pieces are also active well kind
of more active compares to yours as well
my rook and my bishop then my king is
coming
out as well pretty fast so i do like
this
i would go for this if bishop d3 but
bishop e2 i think 58
is very um just
i don't think anybody would do anything
else besides rd8
it's a check it pushes the king away and
it gives us the chance to
um kind of mess with the pawn structure
so
question shall we mess with the pawn
structure
so should we take on e3 or do you think
your knight
is generally better than that bishop and
you don't want to do that exchange
another thing to think about when we are
trying to make decisions about
exchanging stuff is um converting
advantage
so if you think you have a special
advantage or peace activity advantage
even if it's just a
tiny advantage uh you can always convert
this to something bigger
the way i think about it is i am not a
big physics fan
but i always understood and kind of
respected
the law of physics that the energy
conversion stuff
so if you are a nerd you like physics
first of all whoa good for you second of
all um
i think that's that's the easiest way to
understand converting advantage
converting energy
well i guess the problem is with
advantage you can blow it up you can
just blunder it away
but with energy you can't so
i guess there is a flaw in my idea but
ah
let's we do we are strong players we
don't plunder
right okay so um
just thinking about the advantage we are
going to convert our advantage uh which
is
minimum of just spatial and activation
to leak pawn
now the biggest question is okay we
converted this advantage
but how are we going to use it because
we have to be able to use this advantage
otherwise
what do i want to do with an advantage
put it on a shelf i have to be able to
use it
so now what
what is black's follow-up plan
the one thing is certain you got to get
the king out how
also it would be pretty awesome if the
bishop was already on e4
but well i can't dream so question to
audience
like to move what is your plan even if
you don't have a
exact move order having a plan would be
beneficial
see what is the chat saying
i still don't see much from the chat
am i ha well either you guys need coffee
or my i'm not fully up to date
um maybe give me a thumbs up or
something if you are
if everything is all right because i'm
getting a little worried
as you might be aware of
i've been experiencing some um
internet difficulties working from home
so
i'm a little worried i'm not seeing the
chat but let me just reload the chat
okay so it is up you guys just need more
coffee it's okay
we can you can go get your coffee we can
just talk about it
right i wanted some answers okay
um so the best way to try
and um somehow
just advance our position is with
f5 at this point it would be ideal if
this bishop was on e4
but it's not realistic like you don't
have enough time
it's very important to
[Music]
to keep the tempe to not lose time to
just to be able to actually
um use your pieces activity because
one thing that i learned
quite well in my younger years
it was the concept that something like
activity
something like um just peace
coordination
are very um fade away very fast
so you're either going to be able to
they're dynamic so you're either going
to be able to use them
fast quick get them done or most likely
you're going to
convert them to something more permanent
such as
this palm for example or
most cases you might just lose them and
you might just
not have that dynamic advantage anymore
so because it's not permanent you have
to try and use them
asap so push i think that's what my
opponent had in mind as well
with c5 i do still think something or
maybe rook d1 was more interesting just
because
um your t-bomb now um
i can't use this pawn as much as i would
like to as much as if i had the rooks on
the board
and just thinking about this position
nothing else my rook is better than your
rook
so you should try and get rid of it
which you won't achieve with c5
with drift d8 with drift d1 you would
achieve that and it
is my best move to take take and
to be completely honest i have
absolutely no idea how to win this
position
i know how to play it but i don't have
like a cookbook of okay you do this you
do that you're going to win this i don't
think there is
much strategy of
how to win it whereas how to play it and
kind of hope for opponents to not play
it as accurate as i would
so my future moves in this position
would be a combination of
trying to do b6 trying to get this king
up
as soon as possible um
i'm still undecided on whether or not i
want g5 it kind of depends on what the
opponent does
but the one thing i know is i kind of
want to slow this pawn so
i would potentially play v6 and now if
you go b4
i'll get the king outs if you do c5
then take tank and i kind of want bishop
d5 but maybe let's just bring in the
king let's be on the same side and this
was in this situation yeah i definitely
want
um g5 but okay
let's go to our game so
in this position my opponent played c5
and this c5 is kind of giving me a new
target to go after so immediately rook
c8
let's go put that pressure um
now b4 is kind of like the only move
and one thing that i'd like to mention
is
b6 is um
definitely worth thinking about it kind
of
feels weird right because if b6
then uh take take okay i can't
understand that we kind of got rid of
this
strong pawn but if not
what if my pawn just pushes this phone
well this is a super weak pawn now i
just have rook c8
and soon enough i'm going to pick this
guy up so i'm not really worried about
that
i would be worried about maybe b4
[Music]
and take take um
rook c8 king b4 pretty much
only move let's throw that check in
there if king
a5 king a5 now my rook is getting in
there
so like i kind of exchanged my work
activity for your king activity so
i think it's um also a matter of taste
i wasn't willing to do that i didn't
trust my rook enough or i don't trust
myself enough to want to allow my
opponent
that much of an activity maybe a super
gm
will have a different mindset than i did
so um
in the game i took oops in the game i
played your c8
i do remember playing b6 later on
and okay let's get the king out
so in this position my opponent played
bishop
c4 but i do think rook d1 was a better
choice
just rick d1 kind of gives a little bit
more to white's position because if he
were to play rd1
and then i play something like v6 now
you do bishop c4 or even like bishop a6
it kind of feels um a little bit
stronger
which obviously doesn't serve that much
of a purpose because the only idea is
that i'm gonna get you to move the rook
so i can play bishop c4
and if you take it now i'll just take
you to the king
now okay now i actually don't want to be
black the king is activated the rook is
activated
okay we shouldn't take that we should
however take on c5
which will be followed with b5 and
now this is the isolated pawn but it's
an extra pawn so
a lot of trades off trade-offs
english issues well so
anyways in the game i found in bishop c4
and i'm gonna try the chat one more time
you guys have been
very quiet
so let's think what should we do in this
position should we take on c4
should we play something like b6 should
we just ignore it
i think this is the longest silence i've
ever
faced on the live stream
it's a little scary i think one of those
horror movies
everything is silent and then scary
scene
but okay so um i'm going to go ahead
and talk a little bit more about this
end game
so i think the two main candidates are
either take
or b6 so it's kind of like a matter of
well of um figuring out
which um which one would you prefer
and i got a message from miss tracy to
refresh my
chat so you guys ah
never mind so it was my chat all along
nice well kind of good to know i wasn't
being ignored uh
thank you i was looking at the youtube
chat i just couldn't
i don't know why it was out of dating
for me
kind of good to know i'm um ah
it's nice ah good to know i wasn't
getting ignored okay
um okay so
um now that i have your attention
oh malaysia nice okay so what do you
want b6 or taking on c4
um so
so uh to answer a question on why we're
not trying to get
past bonds in the center we do want to
get past bonds but we also want to
eliminate opponents from having those
past bonds
so if i were to play something like g5
now then i would give my opponent a
chance to play with d1
which is going to be followed with dirk
d7 because this bishop
is pinned and this is not pleasant so we
shouldn't
we should advance our position but even
more important than that we
shouldn't give our opponent the chance
to
advance his position so as long as i
keep my opponents um
kind of like paralyzed or just unhappy
i'm i'm happy with that as long as my
opponent is unhappy
don't quote me on that but
uh chest wise let's go chest wise
okay um so that is why we should be
only thinking about taking on c4 or
playing b6
so let's think about taking on c4 i get
it it's kind of weird
now you're at helping your opponent's
king whoa but the idea is that because
this rook is not in d1
yet now i'm going to
um do this quick d8
so now i get the um
i get the file and
it's very important because now there's
only one open file so having that
is very beneficial and now the thing is
well what's going to play like this with
c1 we're going to get the king
and it's still a fair game like it's not
like white swinging or black is winning
but i do think that in the game at least
i thought that
v6 is going to benefit me more
because just b6 the idea was kind of
clear
well i'm attacking your pawns and i'm
attacking your bishop but you can't take
because you lose the bishop
you can't really take here just yet
because i
am still going to continue putting more
pressure on your guy
and i would end up take take i kind of
want to say her b8
d8 and i'm going to start basically
harassing your pawns
so
okay that was my idea planet b6 after b6
white's best move is to go for rook d1
and still follow up with the idea now
blacksmoo what do you think we should do
should we already
just take on c5 should we play like the
king e7 to cover d7
what should we do
i do want to do g5 too but i have to
stabilize the queen side
and defend my center
first i see a lot of king e7 but the
problem with king d7
i think king e7 um what if take
you take back and then rook d6 check
and i think that's a serious
um it's at least unpleasant
king e7 level kingy sevens guys
then check and then just king comes to
c4 and you see
white is much much active more active
so i i yeah i don't want this position
nope if there was no king c4 then okay
maybe but king c4 and then this guy's
coming here all these guys are sad the
king is cutty
no no thank you i'll take my chances
with b
take c5 so b takes c5 or d7 doesn't
necessarily work because i have king of
six
and you don't have a d6 because
of this little check over here and then
we take on c5
now c4 for free 67 doesn't necessarily
work
however b5 kind of does b5 is the best
move
and um so
b5 now white's wanting to create a
passport over here
however having an extra pawn in the end
game
especially in this endgame is beneficial
because we're also kind of paralyzing
the king
so my idea is
um well i just want a pawn i don't want
to elaborate d7 so now let's do king
7 um my opponent took
take back king c4 king c4 was also
crucial because if not then i might want
to do c4
myself so king c4
keeping my pawns at bay and okay
finally finally we push pawns
like we had the chance to push this g5
um
maybe five five six months ago but
it wasn't the right time we needed to do
preparation so we did the preparations
we did the g5
so now it's it feels like it's a pawn
race like
white's gonna keep pushing over here i
can't really stop him
i don't know if i want to stop him and
i'm gonna keep pushing over there
so e4
or f4 or
g4 so what do you want i don't think
anybody actually wants g4 just because
g4 g3 and kind of stops it
so let's uh let me scratch that do you
want e4
or do you want f4
oh i see a lot of f4s whoa only one e4
hmm
i mean i feel like so it's kind of it's
really important to try and figure out
which two palms are you going to keep so
let's say if you were to play f4
um the main thing that you would have to
deal with is this e4 because e4 kind of
closes the
square and your king is kind of um
not having the best day of his life so
that's why i chose e4
because yeah e4 then i would have to
deal with the potential g3s
and i can't just push because well i
mean i'm gonna give the pawn back
and um king f5 there's room d5s
uh take well i don't want to take
d7 coming from behind this is possible
this is
still kind of um
be interesting to play but
um i do feel like e4 would give black
more chances than f4 f4 i mean just e4
and i don't really know how to advance
so yes i can play g4
and yes i can try to push f3 but
ideally i want to have these two pawns
so i kind of want to have these two
central pawns so
e4 however in the game my opponent
was a little in rush and he just played
a5
which i thought well why not i'm gonna
push
and um he started playing inaccurately
so in this position he had to either
take it
and take back play rookie one which i
would follow with king e5 because
there's not a rook d5 check
and i really really like this position
to be
super honest um or after f4
he had to play rook e or f1 now if i
take it okay taking is not really good
because the strip comes back we take and
then e4 is also under pressure but
so the two best moves for white is
either to take or two oops not that to
play
rook f1 in the game he still kept on
rushing after f1 played b6
now well after b6 i do have to take it
that's out of the question
and now what to do with black should we
take should we push
do you think both of it is good the game
is almost done we just have to figure
out
how to play accurately
so what do you guys think what to do
of our final questions
um to give you um
like an estimate with um what engines
think
from what i checked
it's uh black is a slightly better but
it's not black it's not like black is
winning black is just like um
something around 0.7.7.8
better but it's still like you can't see
how dangerous it is
so white still does have a chance of
not losing this so just have to play it
accurately
i think after is good but the problem
with f3
is g4 and g4 is blocking my king's
entrance
and i did not really want to deal with
that i wanted to keep my king activated
so
i took this and so whoa a lot of f trees
ever did anybody actually say taking an
e3
wow well good to surprise you right
f3 is all right it's not like a losing
move
but it does give white the chance to
play g4 and block my king's entrance
so that is why we shouldn't do f3
unless you want to kind of
deal with a little bit of disappointment
of not being able to get your kingdom
but
taking is the best one it's kind of easy
after take my idea is clear
i'm just going to bring in the king and
after king e5 oops
that is a blunder this 35 checks don't
really work either
so basketball for white was actually to
try to play rookie one
i would push the king wanting to go up
here
um he most likely well most accurate
move for white would be to try with h4
to just kind of mess with my pawn
structure
now if g4 then there's g3 which kind of
blocks the king again
so there's a lot of there's still a good
fight left for white
but white kind of ignores the king side
and center and just went for the queen
side
which was a huge mistake why shouldn't
have done that
now in this position actually the
winning move for black is c4
because you are simply going to start
marching with everything you got
but i was very happy that my king is
finally free to go
to the attack so i just pushed the king
it wasn't the most accurate move so i'm
telling you to know
that you don't always have to do the
best moves the most accurate ones
but you do have to have an idea a path
to follow
so king e5 b7
rp8 and so
one final question black to move what
should we do should we keep pushing in
the king
should we push any pawn
one that's our final question and i will
show you
the accurate way
oh nice i got a c4 good one
thanks what else
okay i think so everybody is kind of
happy with c4
yeah e2 is also great yeah e2
is even a little more accurate than c4
because rookie one you just bring in the
king
uh so you sacrificed your extra pawn for
the benefits of your other pawns so now
you can just
relax and you can just give this guy up
and just push well actually you can just
push the king this is super winning
you're gonna get that
um however in the game i just went for
c4
and we're king here take and just e2
just get the king and here my opponents
resign
so my point of showing you this game was
to share with you that you don't always
have to
get out of the opening in like a super
winning way
or you don't have to just um
always have the upper hand in the game
in this game as you saw
uh the opening after coming out of the
opening everything was pretty
um even pawn structures was
uh slightly different because i had the
king side majority
he had the queenside majority
and some of the other things to think
about is the technique
i i knew what i was doing i knew i
wanted to activate
my kink i knew i wanted to not to let my
opponent activate his pieces
so and yes the point of the game was to
play g5
of course so yeah um i hope you guys
enjoyed this game it was one of my it
was just one of those games that
um you played beautiful and your
opponent didn't really do like a huge
blunder or
like a he just like maybe the second
best moves or not
as accurate so yeah i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
with that note i am going to hand you
off
to um my
other coach from slu bar so
make sure to go watch his
class of insane and endgame and
yeah tell him i said hi